Hollywood's working hard on a reboot but
it's not another Top Gun movie it's Joe
Biden our 80 year old sandbag adult
presidents getting a movie makeover
courtesy of Tinseltown producer Jeffrey
katzenberg and he sure needs it 74
percent of Americans think the country's
on the wrong track and 68 percent are
concerned about the president's physical
and mental health
to save his shot at reelection the movie
Mogul thinks Biden should own his age
and turn it into an asset the same way
fellow old guys Harrison Ford and Mick
Jagger have done
and while Biden works on getting us
getting swole like Indiana Jones looks
like he's got some competition RFK Jr
getting ready for a Democrat debate
while looking like the most jacked
presidential candidate in history Biden
still won't agree to the matcha but how
about a push-up contest
let's go
let's go let's go
Dana Perino is oh I'm so glad you went
to me first female and a and an
undecided voter oh okay
when you see RFK Jr like that does that
make you reconsider voting for him
oh gosh you've really put me on the spot
there
um I'm impressed right at 69 years old I
think it is interesting he's trying to
show the contrast while Hollywood is
telling the White House just Embrace
Biden's age it's not as the thing is as
we've said before everyone ages
differently at a different rate that's
not your fault a lot of it has nothing
to do with it now you could maybe take
care of yourself you could do a lot of
exercise Etc but sometimes it's just
genetics sometimes things happen to you
as you age and we all have eyes and ears
we can see what's happening with Joe
Biden's why those numbers are what they
are those numbers are based on likely
voters are registered voters Republicans
Independents and Democrats not just
Republican voters who think Joe Biden
shouldn't move forward it's actually
Democrats who are concerned about his
age so I understand that desire I do
think that RFK Jr
should probably run as an independent
because there are more Independents in
this country registered Independence
than there are Republicans and Democrats
he's not going to get the debate with
Biden he's just not going to get it and
if he wants to actually make a dent and
this could be the year where a third
party do you think the Mansion is a
better Third Party candidate than RFK Jr
like to me I think with his shirt off
but but the other thing I would like to
say is when well do you want to we could
make that see if we can get that on at
seven or eight pm tonight but I I also
love the idea of comparing Joe Biden to
Harrison Ford so katzenberg's like I
know I know what you should do you
should just make this like a little
story well anytime the left listens to
Hollywood they end up in this little bit
of a pickle this is not a storybook
these people are dealing with real
issues real lives they've got real
problems and they're concerned about
their choices going into 2024. Greg
Gutfeld you've embraced your age
yes I have
I have what point are you trying to make
Mr eight o'clock oh shut up mister I'm
so important now because I have a new
job screw you
look
that guy RFK Jr he's in amazing shape
unbelievable shape for 70. but it's easy
when you have all that free time he
doesn't drink like when you don't drink
that immediately that like that that
frees you up the guy's like a he's a
fisherman he's an Explorer he's a writer
he does all of these things because he's
just got to fill up that day so you're
saying if you didn't have two shows
you'd look like that oh Barry I do look
like that already I just choose that by
the way this is very clever of him he's
not calling out Joe for being old and
feeble he's allowing the viewer to make
that comparison himself by just showing
what great shape he is he is that's a
natural I mean I don't I'm not making an
accusation I'm not saying that he might
be doing testosterone with with a uh uh
a double of uh it was epic but but who
knows but it's interesting to me and I
know that uh you know a lot of people
think that he's fringy and he will have
certain beliefs about vaccines that are
troubling but it's so interesting to me
when you when people that are considered
outside the world of Health look like
that and the people who are criticizing
him like Hotes who looks like he spent
his entire life in the cake aisle at
ShopRite it's pretty funny that the
so-called MD's and experts always look
sick but it's the people with the
unorthodox ideas that look like that and
I think it's because people who are into
health and fitness are tend to have an
open mind and their mind gets too open
so they'll be I'm gonna try this
supplement I'm going to try this hormone
but I also think that so you get that
kind of weird thing last point about I
think it makes sense that Hollywood
would uh pair with Joe Biden because
he's living
life like an actor he has to stand on
his Mark he reads his lines he has no
more depth than exactly what he's doing
right there at that moment and then he
goes home he actually works at a set
right they have a set for the Oval
Office he truly is a cog and a larger
Enterprise the only thing that's missing
for this poor guy is a stunt man because
of anything that Joe needs is a stunt
man he keeps falling he's going to kill
himself if he just get get him a stunt
man
it's because
men and women are equal judge do you
think that female presidential
candidates should
take a page out of RFK you're looking at
me like you're going to kill me
I tell you is don't even finish the
question
look um do you want to go there please
let's not okay uh first of all what Greg
is saying is accurate all politics is
theater it is theater and if anyone
thinks it's anything other than theater
they don't know what real politics is
all about it's about an image it's about
you having your lines it's about you
appearing before people as a wonderful
guy who wants to kiss babies when you
want to be in the back smoke a cigar and
having a drink okay
um the amazing part of it is when
Hollywood and and Tick Tock I mean you
know Biden is not so stupid in embracing
those people tick tock and Hollywood but
you know you you would think by the way
that for 50 years in office he's been in
public life for 50 years and figured it
out by now and the idea that katzenberg
said you know look at Mick Jagger
Dancing cross the stage first of all Joe
Biden couldn't walk across the stage and
then he was you know you should be able
to sing and all that stuff he you know
he would need a teleprompter for the
words but but that's not the point the
point is that the Democrats have gotten
together other they've made a decision
he's our guy and the Republicans should
do that and I believe that if Donald
Trump becomes a nominee and he is at
least 30 points ahead of everyone else
then I still don't think the Republicans
are going to come together and you have
to admire the Democrats for what they do
they are one party and that's the end of
it one candidate now as for RFK I'm
impressed with the guy I am very
impressed with him now um I know that he
was always a River Keeper he's an
environmental guy I know he truly
believes in what he says and does and
that's why I think America is going to
like him he's not a politician he's not
a candidate he says what he believes and
what he thinks and I love these little
videos I mean he goes to the Border he
goes you know to the crime areas you
know he's a real guy who's talking about
real issues that Americans want to talk
about and so you know I think that you
know Joe Biden whether or not you know
he's a candidate I mean it seems that
way but he doesn't need Hollywood to
tell him what to do
how does the Biden White House see this
prison type workout that RFK Jr is doing
I do not think they care at all they've
seen it though well everyone's seen it
how you felt about it varies depending
on your political affiliation and I hate
to be Debbie Downer but I'm paid to do
so so I'm going to tell you again to be
Debbie down yes
no democrac real live Democrats that
believe in the Democratic party and what
it stands for like RFK they also do not
think that that is natural to Greg's
Point don't know what he's on don't want
to surmise it's not normal for a 70 year
old there also weren't that many weights
on that bar
weight shaming wow and I'm not saying
they were lady pushers why is that not
normal for a 70 year old don't even go
there all right well I'm gonna go there
in that shape when they're 70. I'm sorry
and women sure my mom is 70 and she
looks amazing
but that man's body
does not look like any seven year did
not look like what my dad looked like
even before and work out constantly this
guy's working okay absolutely
I don't want a guy who could be an
assistant trainer at Planet Fitness to
be the president
why do you want to give a Newsome isn't
he the good looking at isn't that are
you talking about hire anyone based on
how attractive they are I'm interested
in their policies
it's a fact sure being good-looking
helps in life tremendously no matter
what you're doing tell me about it
Jessica think about him uh participating
with other world leaders that aren't in
good shape concerto could take him in a
second oh my God is disgusting can I
dare you
yeah how dare me I'm the offensive one
at the table
um so there was a poll this weekend that
came out from NBC that had Biden beating
Trump by four but had him tied with
DeSantis and losing to DeSantis in the
swing states by six points
at the same time you see Republicans
generally consolidating around Trump
right so the signals coming out are if
it's Trump you'll lose the general
and it doesn't appear that Republicans
are getting that message and they're
people you know raising popularity Tim
Scott for instance is doing better Chris
Christie is picking up a little bit of
steam still at five six percent so Biden
is sitting there thinking okay it's
going to be the guy Thrice indicted
maybe what is it how would you say four
Sunday four times indicted Whatever by
the end guided quad dated yes um and
he's sitting there saying I'm up over 20
points with women I'm up 35 points with
18 to 34 year olds Latinos that number
is back up and he had been struggling
with them 66 okay can we just talk about
him with his shirt off I mean you're
boring everybody
I I said I led with I am paid to be
Debbie Downer and so I'm here for that
anyway look at that okay I mean how dare
you accuse him of being awesome
water turns people transgender he cannot
be president is that true what that's
why I don't drink water
coming up next yeah I want to Brian kill
Mead I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now